I've been failing in communicating so
right now we agree with each other and
we're you know almost echoing the same
sediments so that person that doesn't
agree with us that that vegetarian vegan
the conservationists that looks at us
like no no you guys are hunters you
can't be conservationists where does the
conversation start where is the middle
ground where you can find what one where
an opportunity to build rapport and have
a conversation have a discussion to have
maybe even a debate where you can
intellectually talk through your
different perspectives I've been failing
at this miserably of late and I've been
getting a lot of it's it's weird when my
social media a lot of think I have a lot
of conservative military you know
pro-second amendment types that follow
me when that whole entire base is mad at
me which is weird and then on the other
side the the far left progressive side
is looking at me and be like oh we hate
you too so I'm like I have now pissed
off 95% of people on social media
because I'm trying to find middle ground
so we can talk have you pissed off the
Conservatives yeah have you done that
um length Lance Armstrong and I were
talking about gun control after the the
parklands shooting in Florida and he
asked me do you think gun controls a
solution and I said absolutely I think
gun control can be a massive solution
verbatim that's exactly what I said
now to me gun control those are words
words like well-regulated militia the
words in the Constitution that that's
almost synonymous to me gun laws also
format gun control just like a
well-regulated militia I think that
having good safe gun laws save lives I
don't want a type of felon an ms-13 guy
and illegal immigrant somebody that's
been dishonorably discharged for the
military to get their hands on a gun we
have those laws those are forms of gun
control in my opinion but the
Conservatives second amendment if you
use the words gun control like I was
immediately called Benedict Arnold I'm a
traitor
I was a Duff I don't even know what a
Duff is that was a reoccurring one I
think was the guy from Roger Rabbit the
guy that would hunt around with the gun
but he didn't know how to use the gun
because he always missed Roger Rabbit do
you mean Bugs Bunny yeah yeah Bugs Bunny
step that's no Elmer Fudd yeah a foot
that's what they called me bud yeah so
like hundreds of people and I would just
I'm trying to have a conversation with
Lance Armstrong a guy that had never
shot a gun at the time that was against
private private citizens really owning
guns and he couldn't be more for gun
control but I wanted to talk to him yeah
and so I had no problem using his
vernacular using you know the words that
he's comfortable with like gun control
even though to me that's just gun laws
that's well-regulated militia I mean I'm
a huge second member of Ramona I don't
think anybody has ever questioned that
until this moment if they just pay
attention to you for five minutes all
they have to do is just go to your
social media and you know it's not an
anti-gun guy no guys on the range how
many days a week six fire come on yeah
like I'm mad that I'm here with you I'm
out on the range yeah but I'll make it
up tomorrow
yeah you're you're a gun nut yeah for
sure for sure that meets an Occupational
thing yes I have no choice this is this
is this is what I do now if you want to
be excellent at your job you must be
again yeah well in that conversation I
disavowed apparently my my huge group of
Second Amendment loving people I have a
theory on that I think there's a lot of
people are just looking to get pissed
off and if you say any word that they
decide is a hot-button word like gun
control they don't care if you've
thought it out you have a rational
perspective on what you consider gun
control like there was a statement that
was released by a group of hunters it
was hunters for gun control and they had
a bunch of reasonable reasons why people
shouldn't have a firearm that could get
a firearm currently and it all made
sense but the the response to that the
backlash of it doesn't it's not debate
it's like people on that that
side the pro-second amendment side they
are so terrified of any new regulation
and they think that you have to hold
your ground because any slipping
backwards is gonna eventually lead to
someone taking your guns away I mean I I
do understand the death by a thousand
cuts you know I think that has always
been the perspective you know if you
look at it's not like Adolf Hitler said
okay we're gonna kill all the blacks and
all the Jews overnight that's not what
happened right it was it was over the
course of seven eight years where he
just very slowly incrementally changed
laws okay they're not allowed to shop
here okay they're not allowed to go here
okay now we're gonna move him all into
the same area and very slowly not slowly
in a matter of five six seven years he
started a genocide of an entire
ethnicity and that's that fear it's okay
it's gonna be it's gonna be incremental
and we're and at some point we're gonna
turn around and look and be like look at
all this freedom that we've lost I think
it's the same you know I with during
right after 9/11 when George Bush you
know that the Freedom Act or the Patriot
Act the Patriot Act you know like that
was one of the largest losses of privacy
that Americans have ever ever
experienced but we were fearful we were
scared and you know like I love
dangerous freedom but overnight we lost
a ton of that not incrementally just
overnight and and but the most efficient
way is to take it bit by bit by bit so I
get that but for Christ's sakes man I'm
like you can't find somebody that's more
of a proponent second than me except
apparently on that day when I pissed off
so I'm trying to figure out how to have
a conversation I can't do it I don't
think that there are any more of a
second Amendment proponent than you are
I just think they're ideologically so
rigid in this idea that you can't change
gun laws at all if you think that
someone who's on anti-psychotic
medication
there are bouts of manic schizophrenia
you think that person should be allowed
to have guns when they hear voices that
aren't real they see things that aren't
really there to be reported the FBI
handful of times the sheriff knows about
them the colonel knows about them the
per well obviously the problem with that
is someone can decide to report Tim
Kennedy they can make up some story like
Tim Kennedy has been acting crazy
Tim Kennedy's doing the same he's gonna
kill my fam
Tim Kennedy's doing this Tim Kennedy do
someone just decides to actively target
you in that way they can sort of frame
you as some sort of a crazy person and
then use that as an excuse to go after
your guns I mean this is what people are
terrified of yeah and that is possible
it is I mean there's an objective and
there's no due process on the back side
okay so if somebody was wrongfully put
on a list or you'd not be allowed to buy
a gun how do you get off that list right
I don't know I mean is a guy that spends
quite a bit of time yep but I think
hopefully protecting gun laws and
protecting gun ownership I don't even
know how to get off that list
no that's care probably don't ya ever
get off it's like the no-fly list
there's just not a way to not get off it
who the [ __ ] ever gets back on the fly
no you were off the list but you're back
on come back get more no worries sit
near the window no I'm a beverage
service and peanuts please yeah it's
it's one of those things where there's a
left side and a right side if you say
something that the left believes in
you're a traitor
and if you say if you're on the other
side if you say something the right
believes and you're a traitor no
conversation has to happen in the middle